One thing Marvel has done constantly over
the years is make us laugh.
It’s no coincidence that the MCU’s poster
child is king of one-liners Tony Stark, and
they’ve kept the comedy coming with characters
like Peter Quill and Scott Lang, but the record
shattering Deadpool proved that Fox is no
slouch in the joke department either.
Here are the Most Hilarious Marvel Movie Moments
So Far
Deadpool opening credits
The opening minutes of Deadpool quickly establish
that this is going to be a superhero movie
like no other.
It’s a perfect encapsulation of the film
itself by being self reflexive, visually impressive,
and hilarious.
It acknowledges the archetypes the film will
include in the least archetypical way with
credits like “God’s Perfect Idiot” standing
in for Ryan Reynolds and “An Overpaid Tool”
for director Tim Miller.
A moment frozen in time, the picture speaking
a thousand words as Deadpool tea bags one
goon and gives another a wedgie while the
SUV they’re all in rolls down the highway.
The only question remaining is: who carries
a Green Lantern trading card in their wallet?
Ant Man “Baskin Robbins always finds out.”
Comedian Gregg Turkington was best known for
his stage alter ego Neil Hamburger before
appearing in Ant-Man, now Marvel fanboys everywhere
recognize him as Baskin Robbins’ chill but
firm manager.
He only appeared in one scene, but Scott Lang’s
firing is one of the best in Ant Man, as Turkington
expresses equal parts approval and indifference
while laying off Lang for the “cool” crimes
he lied about to get hired.
Friend and fellow ex con Luis should have
warned him
Spider-Man trilogy -Bruce Campbell
In all three of Sam Raimi’s Spider-Man films
there was one person you could always count
on to show up for a laugh.
Okay, two if you count JK Simmons’ dead-on
J. Jonah Jameson, but we’re talking about
Bruce Campbell’s trio of cameos in different
roles.
Having worked with Sam Raimi on all three
Evil Dead movies, Campbell was a close friend
of Raimi’s and first showed up in the Spider-Man
universe as the ring announcer when Peter
Parker tries wrestling for cash.
Whether as a wrestling announcer, theatre
usher, or snooty French waiter, Campbell and
Raimi seemed to enjoy always finding new ways
for him to insult Parker.
Guardians of the Galaxy -fake leg for the
escape
Marvel made a wise choice when they recruited
indie writer/ director James Gunn to adapt
their obscure Sci Fi adventure property that
was Guardians of the Galaxy.
Gunn’s script is filled with memorable gags
and great jokes, but there’s one that’s
so well placed you can’t help but laugh
every time.
While the escape from the Kyln showed off
the abilities of every almost Guardian, there’s
one character who misses out on most of the
action while carrying out a fool’s errand.
While Quill didn’t think it was very funny
that he paid 30,000 units for a fake leg that
Rocket didn’t actually need, watching someone
screw with the hero like that in the middle
of a big action scene was easily one of the
funniest moments in a movie filled with them.
Avengers -Captain America
Whedon really was in his comedic element when
finding ways to make the Avengers interact
for the first time, he even managed to make
Captain American funny.
With Stark throwing around pop culture references
covering everything from Point Break to Rock
of Ages, the man out of time can barely contain
his excitement when Fury makes a pre World
War II reference.
Fury was of course referring to the flying
monkeys in Wizard of Oz.
While we see him catching up on pop culture
in The Winter Soldier, he still has a ways
to go when it comes to technology.
X Men: Days of Future Past Quicksilver’s
run
If there’s one X Men member who has the
time and good sense to stop and smell the
roses, it’s Quicksilver.
Like the Deadpool opening credits, Quicksilver’s
run in Days of Future Past isn’t just great
on a technical level, but also shows off the
new character’s devil may care attitude.
As the bullets fly towards his allies, Quicksilver
takes a moment to taste some soup, borrow
a guard’s hat and partake in several other
funny bits of business before deciding it’s
time to see where those bullets are at.
And in case you didn’t already realize Quicksilver
had a great sense of humour, they threw a
wedgie in for good measure.
Thor - I need a horse
Just as Captain America needed to get with
the times once he was thawed, there was also
an adjustment period for Thor when he came
to earth.
Unfamiliar with Earth and its customs, the
film made sure to highlight the humour in
the situation, particularly when Thor is in
search of horse and heads to the nearest pet
store.
In a way Thor ends up getting his wish when
Jane gives him a ride in a Pinzgauer 716 truck,
which is actually named after an Austrian
breed of horse, although that was probably
just a coincidence.
Iron Man 3 -The Mandarin reveal
Say what you will about Shane Black and Iron
Man 3 quote unquote ‘ruining’ what many
fans consider to be Stark’s number one nemesis,
Ben Kingsley acted the hell out of that part.
He was sufficiently menacing as the Mandarin
in the propaganda videos, but it’s the Trevor
Slattery reveal where the comic gold lies.
As a washed up English thespian whose King
Lear was once the King of Croydon, Kingsley
creates numerous droll asides in his few minutes
of screen time.
He clearly had a lot of fun with the role,
which is why he came back for more laughs
in the Marvel short All Hail The King.
Howard the Duck
The first feature length film based from a
Marvel property was actually the 1986 George
Lucas produced Sci Fi comedy Howard the Duck.
At the time the comedy didn’t really land,
nobody found the horny duck funny or charming
and the movie was a huge flop.
30 years later, the humour still doesn’t
really work the way it’s supposed to, but
the entire film itself is kind of one big
joke.
Just the fact that something this bad was
made on a scale this big is hilarious and
was a risk only someone like Lucas could have
taken.
From duck boobs (@4:24) to loose duck rubbers
(Howard’s unwrapped condom in his wallet
@19:25), it’s still unclear who exactly
this movie was intended for.
Avengers Shawarma
Fans who weren’t satisfied with just at
the Thanos tease at the end of Avengers and
stayed until the very end for the second cut
scene were rewarded with one of the best pieces
of comedy to come out of the MCU.
The gang sitting around eating shawarma too
tired to speak is a familiar scene to anyone
who’s ever grabbed a bite with friends after
a night of drinking.
In this case the heroes weren’t hungover
from consuming dangerous amounts of alcohol,
just exhausted from saving New York City from
an alien invasion.
The scene was an afterthought, shot after
the cast and crew reunited for the premiere.
Chris Evans had to wear a prosthetic on his
face to cover the beard he was sporting for
his Snowpiercer role.
It was a brilliant move by Joss Whedon, as
the 30 seconds of silence provided one of
MCU’s most memorable and now iconic scenes.
With so many to choose from, these were just
a few of the Marvel scenes that we got a kick
out of.
What scenes made you laugh out loud?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe for my videos like this one.